-Il a commencé comme youtubeur.
Il a d'ailleurs
fait profiter Jean-Luc Mélenchon
de ses talents sur le web
avant de se lancer lui-même
en politique et d'être élu député
sous les couleurs
de La France Insoumise.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Antoine Léaument.
-Bonjour.
-En quelques années,
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est devenu
la personnalité politique
la plus suivie sur YouTube.
Il a 2,6 millions
d'abonnés sur Twitter,
2,1 millions sur TikTok.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est,
au moins en partie, grâce à vous ?
-Oui, en partie.
-C'était votre rôle ?
-C'était mon rôle, c'est vrai,
de construire une équipe
depuis maintenant
de nombreuses années.
Je pense
que ce que j'ai su faire,
c'est trouver les gens
qui savaient faire.
Moi, je maîtrisais
une partie des choses.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
a de l'appétence pour ça.
Il aime beaucoup trouver
des manières
de faire passer
son discours politique.
La force de ses réseaux sociaux,
ça tient au fait
qu'il essaye
de faire passer
un message politique,
programmatique,
sans faire de la com'.
Parfois, il y a un peu de com'.
-On va en parler.
-Il essaye de faire passer
un message politique.
Ca dit beaucoup des raisons
pour lesquelles l'attachement
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon est d'abord
un attachement
à des idées.
Il a réussi à faire passer ça
par les réseaux.
-On va parler
de votre rôle
aux côtés
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
mais d'abord,
j'aimerais qu'on écoute la façon
dont il parle de TikTok.
Vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez.
*-Je me téléporte.
Le 10 avril,
on vote.
C'est l'élection présidentielle.
On vote.
TikTok,
C'est un mode d'expression.
Il faut le prendre
pour ce que c'est.
Si c'est de la peinture,
c'est de la peinture.
C'est pareil pour la musique.
Le TikTok, c'est TikTok.
Vous allez pas faire
du YouTube à TikTok.
C'est un art,
il faut apprendre.
-Est-ce qu'il a bien compris
ce que c'est, "le TikTok",
comme il dit ?
-Il a totalement compris.
Il y a une grammaire
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Chaque réseau en a une,
c'est comme une langue.
Par exemple, je suis bon
pour faire un risotto.
Je peux vous l'expliquer
en français.
Si vous me demandez de le faire
en russe, je pourrai pas.
Il faut que j'apprenne la langue,
c'est pareil pour les réseaux.
Il faut d'abord apprendre les codes,
la langue de ces réseaux.
Ensuite, c'est réussir à faire
entrer le discours politique
à l'intérieur de cette langue-là.
La force
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, c'est
de s'être imprégné de la manière
dont fonctionnent
ces réseaux sociaux.
-C'est le 1er homme politique
que j'ai vu,
par exemple sur YouTube,
inviter ses abonnés à appuyer
sur le pouce ou autre.
C'est ça,
les codes des réseaux sociaux.
-C'est... Ouais.
-Mais venant de lui,
connu pour être un tribun érudit,
diplômé de philosophie
et de lettres modernes,
ça surprend.
Ca a été compliqué
de le convaincre
d'aller vers ça ?
-Pas du tout.
Jean-Luc a toujours cherché
à être indépendant
de ces modes d'expression.
Il a fait un blog
en 2008,
quand c'était l'époque des blogs.
Il existe toujours.
Il avait fait le minitel aussi,
quand c'était l'époque.
Jean-Luc aime bien dire :
"Quand j'ai commencé
à militer,
"on tournait les tracts
à la ronéo.
"Maintenant, je peux faire
des tracts à 2 millions de vues."
-Il parodie Wejdene.
-Tout à fait.
"Macron, tu hors de ma vue."
-Ca fait partie de ces codes-là.
Réussir à capter les choses
qui se passent
sur les réseaux,
car il y a un monde parallèle.
-Ca a fait beaucoup de vues.
-C'était un carton.
C'était le lancement
du compte TikTok.
On avait réussi à capter un truc.
Il y avait une blague
sur "La République,
c'est moi",
un peu d'autodérision
sur le moment des perquisitions.
Ca avait bien fonctionné.
On a réussi à bien faire fonctionner
ses réseaux.
Dans une large mesure,
le score qu'on réalise
chez les jeunes, qui s'informent
avec les réseaux, vient de là.
Il vient aussi du fait
que ça intéresse Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
C'est pas quelqu'un qui va prendre
une boîte de com'.
Il aime ça.
-Derrière ses vidéos,
il y a aussi
une vraie stratégie.
Vous disiez :
"On fait pas de la com'
sur les réseaux sociaux."
En même temps, en 2017,
vous expliquiez :
Le "vous",
ce sont les journalistes.
C'est vrai que c'est enquiquinant,
les journalistes.
Ca pose des questions,
ça empêche les politiques
de dérouler leur discours.
Alors que sur YouTube,
on fait ce qu'on veut.
-Exactement.
-Donc c'est de la com'.
-Non, justement.
Le système médiatique a des défauts.
Il impose
des thèmes et un temps.
Ce que permettent
les réseaux sociaux,
c'est de s'extraire de ça.
Parler de la VIe République
dans une matinale France Inter
de 8 minutes avec des questions
sur l'immigration, l'insécurité
ou autre, c'est compliqué.
Mais si vous faites
une vidéo YouTube,
vous pouvez faire 30 minutes
sur la VIe République.
Ca permet d'expliquer.
-On va parler
de votre parcours politique.
Avant le mélenchonisme,
vous avez été bayrouiste
sur la campagne
de 2007.
Vous aviez presque 18 ans.
Qu'est-ce qui vous attirait
chez François Bayrou ?
-Plusieurs choses.
C'était Macron avant l'heure.
Il proposait :
"La droite, la gauche,
"tout ça, c'est un peu vieux.
"Ca sert à rien.
Je veux faire travailler
"ensemble les gens
qui veulent faire des choses."
Il parlait d'une VIe République.
C'était une République
présidentielle,
et je me suis mis à distance de ça,
mais il y avait des choses,
y compris sur les médias.
Dans une interview marquante,
il avait dit à Claire Chazal :
"Vous, votre média,
"c'est Bouygues, qui est l'ami
de Nicolas Sarkozy, donc..."
-Vous avez vu en lui
un candidat antisystème ?
-C'était un peu le candidat
qui sortait du cadre.
-Mais avec une sensibilité
en même temps
de droite et de gauche,
à l'époque ?
-Ben, ma mère était de droite.
Maintenant, elle vote
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
mais elle était gaulliste
et mon père, de gauche.
Donc la moyenne en 2007,
c'était François Bayrou.
-Comment vous avez
basculé ?
-Il y a eu plusieurs choses.
Il y a d'abord eu
la réforme des retraites.
Déjà, le MoDem
a pas fait grand-chose
après 2007.
Ca a été un peu mou.
La réforme des retraites
de Sarkozy en 2010
m'a montré qu'il y avait
un problème.
La crise des subprimes...
Les banques ont spéculé
contre la dette des Etats,
et la conséquence,
c'est qu'on a fait
la réforme des retraites
pour sauver la dette.
Et j'ai découvert le livre
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2010,
"Qu'ils s'en aillent tous"
et que j'étais d'accord
avec 95 % de ce qu'il disait.
Ensuite,
je me suis rendu compte
que les 5 %
où je n'étais pas d'accord,
il avait raison.
-Vous vous êtes engagé pour lui...
-Je me suis engagé, oui.
-Mais sous pseudo, au début.
-Oui.
-Vous n'avez pas assumé
publiquement et vous expliquez
que ce n'est pas évident
d'assumer cela.
Vous vous dites que ça va
peut-être constituer
un frein pour l'avenir.
Vous n'étiez pas encore
un Insoumis dans l'âme.
-C'est pas ça,
c'est que là, on est en 2017,
au moment où on fait ça,
et moi, j'ai jamais voulu faire
de la politique un métier.
Je suis sociologue de formation.
Je voulais être chercheur.
C'était ça, mon dada.
Et, d'une certaine manière,
quand vous sortez
du champ de la recherche,
pour pouvoir y revenir,
faut pas montrer
un engagement politique,
surtout
en sociologie.
-Vous aviez peur
d'être marqué au fer rouge.
-Oui, mais c'est difficile
parce qu'il faut
porter la parole
de ce qu'on fait
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Les médias
veulent des personnages.
Moi, j'incarnais
la communication numérique
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Donc au bout d'un moment,
voilà.
-On a découvert un Antoine Léaument
très différent,
à l'Assemblée, en 2022,
pour sa toute première
prise de parole.
On va en revoir un extrait.
-J'étais tremblotant.
*Pour ma première intervention ici,
qu'il me soit permis
de dire un mot.
Je siège en haut de l'hémicycle,
et je veux rendre hommage
à ceux qui nous ont précédés
dans "la montagne"
et qui portaient l'idéal républicain
que nous défendons encore.
Suivant les mots
de Jean Ferrat,
je veux dire qu'ici,
il y a avec nous
la France qui répond
du nom de Robespierre.
-Alors, cet hommage
à Robespierre, au début,
certains ont cru
que c'était une blague
ou une provocation,
mais c'est sérieux.
-Oui,
car Maximilien Robespierre
est au centre
de la Révolution française.
Il porte dès le début
l'idée d'une République
profondément démocratique
et sociale.
Il dit :
"Nul ne peut entasser
"des monceaux de blé
à côté de son semblable
"qui meurt de faim."
-C'est votre modèle politique ?
Tous les ans,
vous commémorez sa mort
à Arras.
-Je le choisis,
car il est très caricaturé.
C'est un personnage
présenté comme l'instigateur
de la Terreur,
un dictateur, etc,
et en réalité...
-Ce qui correspond à une réalité.
-Non, cette histoire-là,
elle est créée par ses ennemis
qui l'envoient à l'échafaud.
C'est une histoire qui est créée.
La Terreur...
-Le consensus des historiens...
-Il n'y en a pas.
-Certains portent
une voix différente.
-Un des ouvrages
qui m'a le plus marqué,
c'est celui de Jean-Clément Martin.
Il explique
comment la Terreur,
le Robespierre dictateur,
ont été créés après sa mort,
pas avant.
-La loi des suspects...
-Je suis pas
forcément d'accord
avec ça. Je dis pas
que Robespierre, c'est parfait.
Sur le droit de vote des femmes,
il s'est pas exprimé.
En même temps,
il défendait dès le début
l'abolition de l'esclavage,
le droit de vote
des Juifs.
Il porte pendant la Révolution
des questions qui sont
d'une modernité absolue.
-Vous êtes
un révolutionnaire ?
-Oui, une révolution citoyenne,
par les urnes.
Un changement de Constitution,
c'est une révolution.
-Lors du débat sur les retraites,
vous avez lancé
une phrase qui m'a un peu marqué.
Vous avez dit ceci.
Il y a un petit côté
"les aristocrates
à la lanterne".
Ca m'a fait penser
à la photo
de Thomas Portes
le pied sur un ballon de foot
avec le visage
d'Olivier Dussopt dessus.
Jusqu'où êtes-vous prêts à aller
pour vos idées ?
-Jusqu'aux urnes...
-Mais pas au-delà ?
-Non, mais...
Je me réfère à un discours critiqué
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
où il dit :
"A bas la mauvaise république".
On lui est tombé dessus.
"La mauvaise république,
donc il est pas républicain", etc.
Quand il y a des polémiques,
j'aime bien rentrer dedans.
Pour moi, c'est un plaisir.
La bataille politique,
convaincre les gens
sur des idées...
-Les mots peuvent être perçus
par les gens différemment.
Ca peut être perçu
comme un appel à prendre les armes.
-On m'aura alors mal compris.
Jamais je n'appelle à la violence.
Quand je dis qu'ils auront
leur prise de la Bastille,
je parle
d'une manifestation.
-Ah, d'accord !
-Mais non, je trouve
que c'est quand même...
J'aime bien les mots.
J'ai une formation de littéraire,
en plus de sociologue.
J'aime bien choisir les mots.
Venir sur cette idée
de la Bastille,
d'une manifestation le 14 juillet...
Pour moi,
c'est une date
qui est centrale
dans notre histoire.
Je célèbre la Révolution
dans ma circonscription.
Au début, tout le monde pensait
que j'étais barré
avec mes histoires,
mais en fait,
je raconte une histoire nationale
qui est révolutionnaire.
C'est l'histoire de notre pays.
La cocarde que je porte,
c'est le symbole de notre drapeau.
Il vient de la Révolution.
"La Marseillaise"
est un chant révolutionnaire.
Notre devise,
Robespierre l'a inventée.
Vous voyez, l'histoire de notre pays
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui,
il vient de là
et j'essaie de porter ce message.
-On va terminer
par notre quiz.
-OK.
-Je vous explique le principe.
Il faut compléter les phrases
que je vais vous proposer.
On y va.
"Avec un tel physique,
"les gens pensent que..."
-Que je suis de droite.
-Ca vous arrive ?
-Ouais, ça m'arrive.
Il y avait
beaucoup de gens
qui pensaient ça au début
ou qui disaient :
"Il vient de Bayrou,
il est un peu chelou."
En réalité, mon engagement
est profondément à gauche.
On peut pas être révolutionnaire
et de droite, ou alors,
c'est une révolution nationale
qui n'est pas ma tasse de thé.
-"Jean-Luc et moi, c'est..."
-C'est une histoire d'abord
de camaraderie.
Désormais, je pense que c'est
une amitié solide et sincère.
Pour moi, ça reste
l'homme politique marquant
du début de ce 21e siècle,
sans doute celui
qui a permis que la gauche,
en France,
ne soit pas réduite
en poussière.
-"Quand je vois
que Louis Boyard
"fait plus de vues que moi..."
-Je le félicite.
-Y a pas de jalousie ?
-Ah non, Louis...
Vous avez trouvé la photo.
Louis, c'est un ami.
Pareil, je le connaissais pas
avant de devenir député.
On s'entend
comme larrons en foire avec Louis.
Vraiment,
c'est un excellent ami
et quelqu'un qui, je trouve,
fait un travail magnifique
sur les réseaux sociaux
pour convaincre la jeunesse.
Vraiment, Louis,
si tu nous écoutes, félicitations.
-Merci, Antoine Léaument,
d'être venu ici.
-Merci pour l'invitation.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA